most people have never put a price on
their relationship with a beloved pet
but caring for them is big business
recent figures show Americans spend more
than seventy two billion dollars a year
on their pets including more than 30
billion dollars just to feed them now
some new food options have appeared
particularly for dogs with ingredients
that rival those we feed ourselves and
it appears dogs can tell the difference
some ground beef potatoes few potatoes
and then just like fresh fruits and
veggies I feel like I'm looking at what
you would make for me yea but we're no
the web is actually preparing a
personalized meal for man's best friend
it's a little bit of pumpkin for them
yeah I mean this is actually great for a
dogs that have like sensitive stomachs
more than ever before
pets are being treated as members of the
family and web is betting their owners
will want to feed them that way I was a
consultant working in pet food factories
I saw they were able to use what they
call 4d so dead dying to seize and
disabled like meats
retching making the product I just
didn't feel super comfortable feeding
that's my dog once and so I started
cooking for him he loved the food that
expanded to kind of my close circle of
friends and then pep late really grew
out of that idea we also have our
barking beef our most popular dish for
the dogs the company's meals are
designed with the veterinary
nutritionist and made in a USDA facility
for about $4 a day dog owners can
satisfy the foodie in Fido with fresh
meal deliveries portion sizes are based
on weight and activity level yeah sit
Barkley my four-legged family member and
loyal pet plate customer Sherlock put
the dishes to the test oh my gosh I
swear I feed him I feed him really these
are the benefits of fresh human grade
food if let's say it's a hundred and
eighty dollars a month to feed that dog
I'm paying about sixty dollars this is a
hundred and eighty dollars to feed a pet
for a month is it for everyone let's say
your dog is a picky eater your dog has a
very sensitive stomach yourself or very
health conscious or your dog is
suffering from allergies my pet plate
could be a great option for you are you
Michael boy if you
feed a 70-pound dog for $30 a month you
can feed a 70 pound kid for $30 a month
and I would you know challenge you to
think about why you're able to do that
and what ingredients allow you to be
able to do that the fresh food market
for animals is becoming more crowded
with companies like fresh pet and just
food for dogs which recently opened this
canine kitchen in Petco's flagship store
founder Sean Buckley says the fair is
good enough for people to eat you can't
go into a kibble factory or something
and actually see the food being made
here they're chopping real vegetables
restaurant-grade meats and they're
making the food right here it's a unique
experience while Millennials are
delaying traditional milestones like
getting married buying homes and having
kids they are adopting more pets and
treating their fur babies like little
human beings animals have now become
part of the family and people have their
dogs sleeping in bed with them they're
traveling dr. John de Young of the
American Veterinary Medical Association
sat down with us at their annual
convention
he says when it comes to diet it's
important to remember that pets are not
people there's still a dog they have
different requirements nutritionally or
behaviorally or anything else for that
matter but that hasn't stopped people's
preoccupation with clean eating in
recent years from crossing over into pet
stores we spray the little pieces down
with a natural bacon flavor take the
gluten free trend which has manifested
itself with labels that scream grain
free capturing attention and dollars why
do people want to have a grain free diet
for their dogs just like grain free
sometimes needs to be popular in people
right now gluten free and grain free
it's a popular myth yeah it's not better
for animals because there are
nutritional requirements are not the
same as ours and the consequences could
be grave from 2014 to 2019 the FDA
received more than 500 reports of canine
heart disease concerned of a potential
linkage to grain free food in July the
agency named more than a dozen pet food
brands most frequently cited in reported
cases of dilated cardiomyopathy or DCM
in dogs which can often result in
congestive heart failure we don't know
that there's definitely a link
right so it's simply at this point be
cautious be cautious studies are being
done and I think more will come out in
the next a couple of months hopefully or
in the near future it seems like every
single day there's two three five new
brands of food out there and diets that
say artists is better because we have
this in it or we don't have that in it
and it's it's really a free-for-all
right now so does there need to be more
regulation in the pet food industry
there is a fair amount of regulation in
the pet food industry it could it be
better perhaps and we really want people
to know that they should be taking care
of their animals based on scientific
fact and well-documented studies whether
that's with good old kibble or one of
the newer fresh food meals a trend some
say is here to stay like pet plates
Ronaldo Webb I definitely believe this
is kind of the way of the future when
you kind of look at kind of where the
industry's going and then kind of you
know look at what the human industry
have done you can kind of see them
following together a little bit so I
expect that to continue I expect her to
kind of be more education for people to
care more about what they're putting in
their bodies as well as what they're
putting into the bodies of their family
members and we do want to point out that
none of the fresh pet food companies
that we mentioned were cited in the
FDA's report now the pet food Institute
whose members make most US pet food and
treats said in a statement that they are
quote committed to the health of pets
and take seriously the responsibility to
make safe complete and balanced food for
our dogs and cats the statement
continues PFI members are collaborating
internally and sharing relevant
information for scientific analysis as
we work together to expand the
understanding of any potential
connection between DCM and diet that's
that heart issue that we mentioned and
the real interesting thing that dr.
young said is if it ain't broke don't
fix it if your dog likes kibble and is
eating kibble and it's happy on kibble
that's great fresh food has another
alternative for them but make sure they
have the nutrients that they need and
you've got to check with your bet on
that I was a little ahead of my time I
went the other way I used to eat my my
dog Trixie's biscuit whoa I did
revelation
I did I meant with me everyday but ok it
was tasty Berkeley Berkeley was housing
but I bargain I'm not I did not starve
him I really mean this he's kind of a
picky eater kind of turns up his nose
and I'm there not there so for whatever
for whatever it is that real food that
food that we might eat I think it was
liver that day that he was making a
liver dog yeah goodness my little bit
little of a motto four-legged for baby
great job Dana thank you